In the old days, it was commonplace
to save text as a graphic.
As you can see here,
that doesn't scale well visually and
adds to the page weight and latency.
Text as graphic can also cause
conflicts with format choice.
Now in theory you might
want to save text in a PNG
format because text has solid color and
hard edges.
But in this example
we've saved as a JPEG
because we're using text over a photo.
Scale that up, and
you start to see artifacts.
Using text as a graphic also means the
text can't be found by search engines,
and isn't accessible by screen readers
and other assistive technologies.
You can see what the current page looks
like in the text only browser Lynx, that
gives a good idea of what screen readers
and search engine web crawlers see.
All you can see here is
the alt text on the image,
which says koala and nothing else.
And you can't copy
text as graphic either.
If you do need to incorporate
text in graphics,
overlay real text over the top.
Simple.
Both the photo and the text display and
scale much better, and
you can select the text.
And it's really easy to
add effects with CSS.
I'm using the Lovely Lobster font,
which is one of the many
free web fonts available.
File size is smaller too because we can
save the photo as a nice small JPEG for
the photo, rather than having
to use PNG to cope with text.
On the subject of text and
images, one way to ensure your
site is really responsive is
not to have any images at all.
Maybe some of the pages on your
website don't need images.
These sites use beautiful
topography CSS effects and
great layout to achieve really
striking graphical effects,
with responsive layouts and
stonkingly fast load times.
Likewise, these sites,
which use images really sparingly.
When you're designing a responsive site,
every time you add a placeholder for
an image,
think about whether you really need it.
Sometimes the best image
is no image at all.
In the past, typography on the web was
extremely limited by the number and
quality of fonts available.
With web fonts and modern CSS
implementations, that's all changed.
Web fonts and CSS enable
beautiful typography on the web
without having to resort
to using text as graphics.